[Music]
the human eye is an amazing mechanism
able to detect anywhere from a few
photons to direct sunlight or switch
focus from the screen in front of you to
the distant horizon in a third of a
second in fact the structures required
for such incredible flexibility were
once considered so complex that Charles
Darwin himself acknowledged that the
idea of their having evolved seemed
absurd in the highest possible degree
and yet that is exactly what happened
starting more than 500 million years ago
the story of the human eye begins with a
simple light spot such as the one found
in single-celled organisms like you
Glenna
this is a cluster of light-sensitive
proteins linked to the organisms
flagellum activating when it finds light
and therefore food a more complex
version of this light spot can be found
in the flatworm planaria being cupped
rather than flat enables it to better
sense the direction of incoming light
among its other uses this ability allows
an organism to seek out shade and hide
from predators
over the millennia as such light cuts
groove deeper in some organisms the
opening at the front grew smaller the
result was a pinhole effect which
increased resolution dramatically
reducing distortion by only allowing a
thin beam of light into the eye
the Nautilus an ancestor of the octopus
uses this pinhole eye for improved
resolution and directional sensing
although the pinhole eye allows for
simple images the key step towards the
eye as we know it is a lens this is
thought to have evolved through
transparent cells covering the opening
to prevent infection allowing the inside
of the eye to fill with fluid that
optimizes light sensitivity and
processing crystalline proteins forming
at the surface created a structure that
proved useful in focusing light at a
single point on the retina
it is this lens that is the key to the
eyes adaptability changing its curvature
to adapt to near and far vision this
structure of the pinhole camera with a
lens served as the basis for what would
eventually evolve into the human eye
further refinements would include a
colored ring called the iris that
controls the amount of light entering
the eye a tough white outer layer known
as the sclera to maintain its structure
and tear glands that secrete a
protective film but equally important
was the accompanying evolution of the
brain with its expansion of the visual
cortex to process the sharper and more
colorful images it was receiving we now
know that far from being an ideal
masterpiece of design our eye bares
traces of its step by step evolution for
example the human retina is inverted
with light detecting cells facing away
from the eye opening this results in a
blind spot where the optic nerve must
pierce the retina to reach the
photosensitive layer in the back the
similar looking eyes of cephalopods
which evolved independently have a
front-facing retina allowing them to see
without a blind spot other creatures
eyes display different adaptations anub
lapse the so called four-eyed fish have
eyes divided in two sections for looking
above and underwater perfect for
spotting both predators and prey cats
classically nighttime hunters have
evolved with a reflective layer
maximizing the amount of light the eye
can detect granting them excellent night
vision as well as their signature glow
these are just a few examples of the
huge diversity of eyes in the animal
kingdom so if you could design an eye
would you do it any differently this
question isn't as strange as it might
sound today doctors and scientists are
looking at different eye structures to
help design biomechanical implants for
the vision impaired
and in the not-so-distant future the
machines built with the precision and
flexibility of the human eye may even
enable it to surpass its own evolution
[Music]